that's the first topic for today's
what's more likely and what is more
likely Chris Sims the 49ers offense
returns to form playing indoors in New
Orleans or the hostile environment at
the Superdome flusters Jimmy G I'm going
with door number one that the 49ers
offense returned returns to form you
know there really hasn't been a game
where the offense hasn't been inform I
think last week yeah the Ravens were
good but I think the weather hurt them
just as much and I don't think Jimmy
Garoppolo is a flustered type guy I
don't you know he made his first career
start on a Sunday night football for the
New England Patriots in Arizona and just
didn't seem flustered there honestly I
think he's got a little bit but I'm
saying this respectfully and this is the
right thing to have a little bit of meet
headedness about him to not be flustered
like not really even understand the
magnitude of the moment which is a good
thing when you play football I'm not
trying to say that in a bad way so yeah
I go with option one and you know the
other thing too and this point has come
up from time to time but it's very
appropriate to mention it again as we
get closer to the next Saints game the
Saints aren't exactly blowing people out
right they're struggling with teams like
the Panthers they ended up letting the
Falcons hang around way too long a
couple of weeks after losing to Atlanta
at home and it's hard to forget that
memory of the New Orleans Saints losing
26 to 9 at home to a hapless at least
this year
Falcons team when we assess this one
because the 49ers understand the stakes
and look that the Saints don't have
someone pushing them in their division
they've already won the division they
don't have to worry about being the five
seed the 49ers do and for the 49ers the
gap is significant as it could be you're
gonna be a five seed you're gonna be the
1 seed and the opportunity to put
themselves in position to be the 1 seed
and avoid being the 5 seed
hinges in certain respects on their
ability to win in New Orleans on Sunday
and just think think about how how
crappy it was in Baltimore and the rain
was blowing sideways and the field
conditions weren't great to go into a
laboratory setting yes in the Superdome
no matter how loud it is it's really
gonna allow the pieces of the offense
and you've been saying all year the way
Kyle Shannon draws up the running game
draws up the passing game puts plays in
place that you or I could make the
throws they're gonna have a lot of that
on Sunday and that that's the
thing that fascinates me about that game
because Cal Shannon Sean Payton are two
of the masters of drawing up plays right
where it pops and it's regardless of the
skills of the individuals involved on
the field it's the way that the X's and
O's are lined up
that gives you an O that has no X around
that's right that's a great way to put
it yeah they're just again they maximize
the town of their guys because they put
them in positions to succeed a lot and
that's by them for lack of a better
phrase screwing over the defense in the
scheme and the defense of play call and
they're masters of that and you're right
that's gonna be one of the chess matches
within the chess match they're watching
those two go at it as far as play
calling all right what's more likely
tonight the Cowboys defense overwhelms
Mitchell true Biscay or the relatively
cold weather slows down the Dallas
office yeah I'm gonna go with the
Cowboys defense overwhelms Mitchell true
Biscay I am you know again you said it
earlier in the show the cold weathers
not gonna be that bad we're thinking 41
with a slight wind all right so that's
not that bad also you know even though
Mitch or Biscay has made some good
throws lately and certainly had some
brighter moments through what three
touchdown passes last week against the
Detroit Lions made some good downfield
throws you know I get I just think the
offense overall isn't good enough around
him there's not enough of a running
attack I will say this watch out for
double moves and things like that I'm
Byron Jones and trudeau ba Woo's a
because they play a lot of like man
coverage or just three deep with a
single safety in the back so I think you
could see that as well all right next
topic what's more likely the Patriots
confused Patrick mahomes again or the
Chiefs are ready for Bill Belichick's
defense well I'm going to go with the
number one again here I mean this is a
tough one you know what do you feel here
I just feel like yeah I mean I feel that
Bill Belichick and the way they have
this defense orchestrated they're gonna
come out with something that Kansas
City's not quite prepared for especially
early on I see that happening more than
then the Chiefs coming out and just
torching Bill Belichick in the defense
but what did we see Sunday night when
the Texans were able to put Hopkins and
will fuller and Kenny Stills out there a
lot of zone and that zone got picked
apart you can't just say to Stephane
Gilmore go take away Tyree kill because
they do have the other weapons that can
put stress on the defense now earlier on
the TV side only Chris showed how the
Patriots were able to slow down
the Kansas City offense in the AFC
Championship game specifically to how to
take away Tyreke Hill I don't think you
can take away everyone and the thing is
right they use that in that game so this
time around Andy Reed will know it's
coming that's part of the chess match
does he expect that does he expect
something else
how does he attack what he sees and how
do that's why they're always looking at
those tablets on the sideline right
there trying to figure out what the hell
they're doing it might be different than
what they expected that's right what's
the attack for today you know oh gosh
it's been the first 20 plays let's see
if we can find a theme for what they're
doing to us in certain formations or
when we have certain personnel sets this
is exactly right Mike that's what they
are looking for and Belichick is usually
one step ahead in that game that's where
he's phenomenal now Andy Reid is a
phenomenal game planner that way as well
and I'm sure New England's the type of
team where they spent a little time in
the offseason have a few tricks up their
sleeve to go after the Patriots as well
this is gonna be a fascinating one it
really is because you know that the
Chiefs are I think trying to change the
way they approach on offense a little
bit everybody's caught on to their
shotgun downfield passing attack and I
think they're trying to add other
elements to the offense right now it's a
little bit of a work in progress I think
it'll be interesting I just I wish then
one thing the Texans did that the Chiefs
aren't good at yet the Texans can run
the ball and they're pretty patient that
way so that could hurt like Belichick to
Kansas City is trying to run the ball
more but I still don't think they're
quite where they want to be and then
that's one thing to watch for and let's
move on to the next one what's more
likely
specifically who's more likely to rush
for a hundred or more yards this week
Lamar Jackson or Josh ow oh I got to go
Lamar Jackson but this one well I would
not be shocked because it's a slow front
seven for the Ravens and you and I you
and I about Josh Allen every week he he
ran for three
hundred yard games in a row last year
actually 200 yard games and then ran for
99 and the third so he is dangerous but
I'm going to go with Lamar Jackson Mike
this is the one thing can people start
talking about Josh Allen a little bit in
the national media I mean the Baker
Mayfield or Sam Donald we're nine and
three everybody be going oh my gosh this
is the greatest thing ever look all
these teams return on their investment
and there's top three picks it was
amazing Josh Allen I mean he was the
star of the show on Thanksgiving and
nobody really talks about it I just
don't understand it are you in the
national media yes I'm trying that's why
I'm trying to and okay well somebody is
talking about challenge yes I'm just
trying to get a little more credit there
but I know you and I like a lotta I'm
giving you a hard time yeah here's the
thing yeah on the surface this is an
easy question because Lamar Jackson
seems to have a hundred or more rushing
yards on a regular basis but and that
Bills defense is gonna the other a pain
in the butt as we begin to understand
more about the way the Ravens deploy
Lamar Jackson and your friend Kyle
Shanahan put it best last week when he
decides to run he is not a mobile
quarterback who is running he is a
running back he doesn't look to throw he
doesn't look to get out of bounds he
doesn't look to slide and I saw him get
down a couple times last week wisely and
not all running backs just continue to
plow into contact because you can't
survive if you do it but you know these
defenses as the stakes get higher in
these games these defenses are going to
come at him and we saw what the Patriots
did to josh allen he tried to run the
ball earlier this year and i think
that's a great teaching point for the
bills defense lamar jackson when he is
running you treat him like any other
running back and you hit him hard and
that's my concern that the bills are
gonna swarm him when he tries to run so
maybe Josh Allen is the guy who comes
out of this one with with more rushing
yardage maybe he's more likely to get a
hundred rushing yards because maybe the
the Ravens defense starts adjusting to
what he's doing in the passing game and
the opportunities will be there for him
too right that's exactly right that's
where I look at it you know that Buffalo
usually does have a player to every game
where it's a design run for Josh Allen
but yeah Josh Allen's stats on the
running game will come through the scram
like you said and it is a little
dangerous the Ravens like to play
man-to-man so their backs will be turned
and they don't have tremendous team
speed on the front seven they're big
they're overpowering they're not
necessarily fast so if he does break the
pocket he should be able to break and
rip off some yards but I'm still going
with Lamar Jackson and you are too right
yeah I think so I think so although it
wouldn't surprise me if it goes the
other way right last one real quickly
yeah which Rams offense is more likely
to show up on Sunday Night Football the
team we saw last week which ripped apart
the Cardinals or the unit that couldn't
score 20 points for nearly a full month
oh man I I think we're gonna go back to
the like around 20 points type offense
again because I think the Seahawks have
got it rolling a little bit on the
defensive side of the ball and I worry
about them controlling the ball with
their run game on the other side I don't
I can't imagine this game being
high-scoring I guess is what I'm saying
you know I think right now just sitting
here I'd go Rams like 20 I mean Seahawks
20 to 17 or 21 17 something like that it
was a barn burner when they got together
in Seattle on that Thursday night it was
I know
nine years ago yeah I think I you look I
I I don't want to be a prisoner of the
moment just because they had a big game
against the Cardinals the Cardinals are
not great now I know the Cardinals have
given teams like the 49ers fits this
year but the Rams desperately needed to
get right and this game has much higher
stakes for the opposing team than last
week's game did and maybe it will be a
close low-scoring groundout type of a
game I expect it to be a great game I
expect it not to be a blowout yeah and I
you know we've seen time and again with
the Seahawks do in prime time and I have
a feeling when we'd make our picks later
today on the joint pft p.m. Chris Sims
unbuttoned mega-pick podcast I'm going
to end up going Seahawks
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports